pour aller on termine par cette
information l annonce de nicolas dupont
aignan comme candidat à la
présidentielle 2022 le député de
l'essonne et président de debout la
france l'a annoncé aujourd'hui sur une
chaîne concurrente il s'était déjà
présenté en 2012 puis en 2010 est où il
avait réuni 4 7 % des voix
puis ils s'étaient ralliés à la
candidate marine le pen au second tour
selon lui les français ne souhaitent pas
d'un nouveau duel entre emmanuel macron
et marine le pen lors de la prochaine
présidentielle
voyez ce qui là est ce qu'il nous dit
justement de ses motivations
la campagne va être très simple quels
sont les défis du pays
premier défi c'est le désordre qui
atteint des proportions incroyables donc
re restaurer l'ordre public
deuxième des filles ce sont les
délocalisations c'est la perte d'emploi
de pouvoir d'achat qui met en péril
notre système social donc il faut
relocaliser un million d'emplois et
j'explique comment bien sûr et puis il
ya plus grave encore c'est la crise de
confiance du pays et la crise de
confiance se sera pas un homme
providentiel qui tombera du ciel c'est
de rendre le pouvoir aux français et
notamment le fameux rich
je veux que l'on puisse avoir un
référendum d'initiative citoyens à la
fois au niveau national et à la fois au
niveau local c'est fondamental on ne
redressera pas la france sans les
français et ce programme précis concrets
je suis convaincu qu'il correspond à ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens sable ans
il faut le temps de leur présenter